we won't go back
abortions are at the moment legal in
Michigan but the women in this room
including the president of the country's
largest abortion provider fear that soon
could change
how much
how are they are trying to take us back
a 1931 Michigan law had banned nearly
all abortions with no exceptions for
rape or incest now that law could return
this
um outrageous dangerous and cruel law
basically means that Healthcare in
Michigan becomes criminalized that women
can be prosecuted for having abortion
for having a miscarriage if they have a
stillbirth that's where Michigan's
proposal three comes in it puts the
question of whether abortions should be
protected in Michigan directly to the
voters signs are everywhere vote Yes to
support abortion access no to oppose it
both sides have been campaigning hard
we're all canvassing in support of
proposal three this father and daughter
Duo have been knocking on doors to
convince voters that abortions should be
protected after learning what the
campaign was she said she'd support it
there is a reason why Michigan is at the
center of the abortion debate raging
across the
but there are about evenly divided
politically a close reflection of the
entire nation and that gives lawmakers
of both parties from Lansing to
Washington a chance to learn what the
average American voter thinks about
abortion and then to adjust their
political strategies accordingly
Republicans have long benefited from
Christian conservatives who support the
party's anti-abortion platform the
priest at the Church of the Resurrection
in Lansing Michigan told parishioners
voting for abortion access would be a
sin
should you vote for proposal three you
need to repent and go to confession
abortion is murder when you're taking a
human life you're murdering that life
but polls show the pro-abortion side
leading by a significant margin in
Michigan the fact that we might not be
able to control what happens with our
own bodies that we don't have that
choice is wrong whether that passion
translates to votes remains to be seen
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Lansing
Michigan